As Halloween 2017 fast approaches, so does
the highly anticipated second season of Stranger
Things, Matt and Ross Duffer's addictive blend
of Steven Spielberg and Stephen King.
The Netflix thriller became the unexpected
hit of 2016 and propelled its young cast members
to levels of fame they couldn't have dreamed
of when they answered that first casting call.
But what are the kids of Hawkins, Indiana
like away from the cameras?
This is what the cast of Stranger Things looks
like in real life.
Millie Bobby Brown
Brown was born in Spain to English parents
and spent her childhood between the UK and
the US.
Before winning the part of psychokinetic runaway
Eleven, Brown had made a few minor TV appearances,
though Stranger Things was her first major
gig.
"Is your mom here?
Your dad?"
"Mouthbreather."
As the breakout star of the show, she quickly
booked a part in Universal's Godzilla sequel,
King of the Monsters, set for release in 2019.
While Stranger Things Season 2 details remain
scarce, the first promotional images released
confirm that the Eggo-loving Eleven will no
longer be sporting her laboratory buzz cut,
instead rocking some very '80s curls.
Finn Wolfhard
In his role as Mike Wheeler, Finn Wolfhard
took center stage alongside his mysterious
houseguest Eleven, showcasing an impressive
range for such a young actor — impressive
enough to land him a part in the upcoming
'80s-set adaptation of Stephen King horror
classic It.
"Wow.
She looks…"
"Pretty… good.
You look pretty good."
In real life, the curly-haired Canadian is
an indie music aficionado who plays guitar
and even has his own band.
Gaten Matarazzo
Even though he had stage experience, Gaten
Matarazzo had only a single screen credit
to his name when he auditioned for the part
of the lovable Dustin Henderson in Stranger
Things.
"Where are you going?
You just said, 'Stick to the plan!'"
"I am!
I'm just going to go get some chocolate pudding.
I'm telling you: Lunch lady Phyllis hoards
that s---."
But his lack of screen time wasn't for lack
of trying: The New Jersey-born actor suffers
from a mild case of cleidocranial dysplasia,
a condition where you're born without a collarbone,
which affects skull growth and teeth.
Matarazzo used his post-Stranger Things fame
to raise awareness of the condition and received
countless letters of support after he revealed
that his disability stopped him from getting
parts for a number of years.
But the Duffer Brothers wrote his condition
in, giving his character Dustin the same condition
and even allowing bullies to use it as ammunition
in the show.
Caleb McLaughlin
Like Matarazzo, Caleb McLaughlin began his
career as an actor on the stage, playing the
young version of Simba in the Broadway production
of The Lion King from 2012 to 2014.
He came into Stranger Things with a couple
of TV credits, like most of his on-screen
friends, but getting the part of Lucas Sinclair
in Stranger Things was the hardest audition
process he's been through yet.
While his character Lucas is the skeptic of
the group and is initially wary of El, McLaughlin
revealed that, off-camera, the cast clicked
"like magnets."
Noah Schnapp
Schnapp originally auditioned for the role
of Mike Wheeler, but was equally excited to
learn he'd won the part of Will Byers when
he got a phone call from the Duffer Brothers
while away at camp.
Schnapp made his film debut in Steven Spielberg's
2015 movie Bridge of Spies — not a bad first
gig for such a young actor.
Schnapp went on to voice Charlie Brown in
The Peanuts Movie before landing the part
of Will.
Schnapp suspects Will won't quite be himself
in the second season.
The actor told The Hollywood Reporter he thinks
Will is going to "become evil" in Season 2.
And seriously, if barfing up slugs during
dinner doesn't make you evil, what does?
Natalia Dyer
Dyer's Stranger Things character Nancy Wheeler
starts out as your typical '80s high school
girl.
But by the first season's end, she's far from
a teen stereotype, diving head first into
the Upside Down in search of her missing friend
Barb.
She told Cosmopolitan it was "really nice"
to see a character like Nancy, saying, quote,
"She does have that love triangle and boy
drama aspect to her, but she's independent
and strong, and her main focus is about finding
her best friend and solving that mystery at
any cost."
Joe Keery
While Steve Harrington gets under your skin
at the start, his change of heart and obvious
remorse come as unexpected and somewhat refreshing
— and even actor Joe Keery didn't see the
switcheroo coming.
The cast members were given the scripts episode
by episode, and had little idea about the
fate of their characters.
Keery was certain he wouldn't be around for
the second season after his questionable behavior
early in the story, telling Marie Claire he
was sure he'd be "monster food."
Fortunately, he lived to the end of the season
— and even became something of a cult-favorite
among fans of that other popular show set
in Indiana, Parks and Recreation.
"You guys heard about this fan theory.
They think that Steve is actually John Ralphio's
real father."
Charlie Heaton
When they're not teaming up with Nancy to
try and rescue Will and Barb from the Upside
Down, Jonathan and Steve compete for her affections
— and in very different ways.
While Steve is the confident, popular type,
Jonathan admires Nancy from a distance with
his long-lens camera, earning himself a reputation
as a bit of a creep.
Their love triangle looks set to continue
in season two, but even if Jonathan isn't
quite as prominent this time around, we'll
be seeing a lot more of Heaton regardless.
The British actor has been cast as the superhero
Cannonball in Fox's upcoming X-Men spin-off
New Mutants.
Shannon Purser
Let's finish things off with fan-favorite
Shannon Purser, who looks radically different
when she's not covered in a thick layer of
pure 1980s.
Barb was a minor character in Stranger Things,
who vanishes pretty early on after being left
alone outside by Nancy while she hooks up
with Steve... and shows up again at the end
of the season when her body is seen in the
Upside Down, an unfortunate victim of the
Demogorgon.
Despite that, Barb became inexplicably popular
among Stranger Things fans.
The "Justice For Barb" hashtag began trending
on Twitter after her character was killed
off, and she became one of the most popular
Halloween costumes of 2016.
Purser told the Guardian that some truly dedicated
fans went one step further in their tributes
to the character, sending her pictures of
Barb's face tattooed on their bodies.
And while Barb's fate seems pretty much sealed
at the end of season one, some dedicated fans
still hold out hope that she'll return for
the follow-up.
Hey...stranger things have happened.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!